hi everybody welcome to be here it's
been I guess this is great segue we're
gonna be talking a lot more about
urinary infections kidding and kidding
we're not going to talk more about your
area infections we're gonna talk about
other stuff can you raise your hand if
you're one of the interns alright I have
kind of designed this presentation for
you so the rest of you just so you know
I'm hoping to kind of get a beginners
audience into some predictive modeling
concepts that we're talking about and so
the title was originally advanced
analytics at an academic Health Center
current status and challenges we have
many and so I've kind of focused in on
one I'll tell you a little bit agenda
for this who are you what did you say
you do and advanced analytics sounds
great and all but can you tell us about
AI and healthcare so we're gonna try to
go over some of those items hopefully
they'll be of interest but also there's
there's a few key takeaways I think
you'll find so Who am I Peter graven I
have a PhD in health economics my
technical role at OHSU is actually lead
data scientist I'm in the IT department
here I I've been there mostly because we
sit on top of all the data and it's a
good place to implement data predictive
models and other things I come from a
background in research both policy and a
lot of kind of methodology I lead an
analytic Services program there I am
technically an assistant professor at
the School of Public Health and I teach
teach health economics there but as I'll
say again I'm really a health economist
and you'll see that that comes up
occasionally what do I do
so as lead data scientist I'm doing
predictive models I do forecasting
models and kind of advanced analytics
for a hospital system that's really
anything statistical in nature a lot of
people do reporting in our in our
healthcare system but not a lot of
people are kind of analyzing it with a
statistical lens and then as part of
leading our analytic services program
I'm trying to consult with on high
priorities to the institution and
understand their analytic needs and like
I said we sit on top of all the data
and so there's many we have access to
many tools to answer questions that are
pertinent alright so advanced analytics
sounds great and all but can tell us
about AI and healthcare and I'm gonna do
this is gonna be kind of a cursory look
but it's gonna lead us to a couple
takeaway points so as you you know if
you kind of read the you watch the news
if you listen to popular reports
artificial intelligence is changing the
world around us right in many sectors
just looking up artificial intelligence
if you go to Google yo you got your
predictive typing right so it's already
trying to predict what you're going to
get it's going to give you some
predictive results so just starting
there we already know that AI is is
trying to understand what you're
thinking are what you want before you
get there
speech recognition obviously we've seen
that deployed in many many settings of
being able to figure out all those
sounds that you are putting together
what does that maybe mean what are you
trying to say
visual perception the ability to
understand what and what images are
that's a form of AI as well and then
marketing and I'm gonna talk about this
one a little bit more we see AI and
marketing quite a bit that is your
Facebook feed that's telling you all the
things you want to buy maybe there's a
reason why we're gonna compare that to
health care and I'll tell you a bit more
about the marketing examples in
marketing a lot of times it's something
as simple as a product recommendation
how do I know what product to offer to
offer to a person if I could figure out
that then I have a whole bunch of
products I want to sell and they
actually probably want to buy a bunch of
them and so making that connection is
something that we've seen from AI in
terms of machine learning right and and
having big data sets about people's
behavior and being able to train a model
that can then look into the future and
figure out what what you might like and
modify itself image recognition may be
you search for one kind of jacket or
shirt and now when you search again it's
gonna say you know I think I know what
they were looking for a last time based
on what was in that image I'm gonna
probably give them a bunch of other
images that look like that so finding a
pattern there they use marketing to
understand like all your chats online
your mood maybe what you're thinking
about your complaints they might want to
fix your complaints before before you
leave their their company demand based
pricing another thing where they're
really looking at how it's you know your
behavior in terms of how much you're
looking for things maybe we're gonna
raise our price because of that so
anyway there's a whole bunch of cases in
marketing which I think has captured
people's interests in many ways about AI
potential in healthcare so we're gonna
transition a little bit and why is a in
healthcare different I'm gonna tell you
a story a little bit about why about
predictive modeling and hopefully this
will kind of give you a sense of it so I
get this a lot my job and someone says
hey let's predict the risk of each
patient right and so like you you get
you can do predictive models right find
out which my patients is risky let's go
let's go build the model and I say well
okay
I'm glad you're so excited you'll see
the exclamation mark there did you see
how excited they are let's you know
let's predict the risk and maybe this
will save clinician time and we'll be
using AI right so it sounds wonderful
and then you know I'll just have like a
little question so you know what model
should we build what what's risk of what
what are we talking about right is that
the risk of cost if you're the insurer
you're very interested in some patients
risk of cost and what kind of costs they
might have but if you're a health care
organization maybe you're interested in
other things like risk of them coming to
your hospital for an admission or a
needy visit right these are expensive
things but they're also times when the
patients truly sick right and so maybe
there's some ways we can get ahead of
that so you know first question is you
know risk of what right and so this is
something that people they brush over
the word risk seems to cover everything
and and we want to as you think about
predictive modeling in the future we're
gonna have to go many layers into what
do you mean by a predictive model okay
the first layer is risk of what
yes they decide yes let's predict
hospital admitted Eve is 'it's that
sounds perfect that's what we've always
wanted to do alright but what will we do
to prevent that Edmund 3d visit Oh
question yeah we have these list of
people that are gonna have an admin or a
needy visit what are we gonna do about
it well I don't know let's look in our
bag of interventions will indicate the
patient for care management we're all
done savanah other exclamation mark it's
all settled do care management alright
but the question is does care management
work for all patients probably not right
you know you're gonna have some patients
where they're gonna respond really well
to whatever it is care management is
doing how many people have ever worked
in care management thank good couple
experienced people now what what do they
do all day we might not know right they
they certainly do and they probably have
different approaches for different
patients right so that might be
something that they try one thing with
the patient to see hey why don't you
come in I'll give you a call remind you
of your visit help you set up your next
one think about a good path for you
but maybe they're like you know I don't
want to do that I don't want to come in
and they're like oh wait I got another
option we're gonna try this other thing
with this patient and so they might have
a variety of different things they're
doing so care management might just be
kind of a big blob or you can start
thinking about what what are they how
are they what are their bag of tools
that they that they have and so then
you're thinking a little bit further
down the line right we started out risk
then we got down into hospital admin
Evie
now we're really trying to predict who's
good for care management right now we're
now we're getting a lot closer to the to
the things that people might like okay
so let's predict the patients that care
management works for we're done we did
it that's great now we got a really
fancy model except for what what does
care management do so we kind of alluded
to that last question we don't we don't
always know maybe they generally engage
or maybe like I said they have different
approaches for different patients and
then here's where it gets tricky right
how do we know if it works how do we
know if care management is
we we started out talking about
predictive models and now we're trying
to figure out if something works well
you know you I guess you could just go
and compare the ones who got care
management to the ones who didn't and
see how they did right did the ones who
got care management in your past
did they have fewer Hospital admits
fewer edy visits seems pretty
straightforward right what's the problem
with that the ones who got care
management were probably sicker to begin
with right we picked them for a reason
so we can't just say oh the ones who got
care management went into the hospital
you know you know 20% of the time the
ones who didn't went in 10 percent of
the time it looks like care management
might be bad for you right so basic
scientific method here is we need to be
really careful about how we decide if
something works and what and what's
going on with it and so in this case you
know it might I might be that we can't
just do an easy comparison of our
populations there's mostly for the
interns here does anyone know what would
be a good way to try to assess if it
works would be a good way to determine
if this something called care management
was working for a population there are
different types of studies that you that
that might be effective for making sure
that there's no other things affecting
what's the result of the
patient and so you can keep thinking
about that I will give you the answer
don't worry because we'll we might run
out of time so we have different study
types that we do on patients one of
which is the randomized control trial
has anyone heard of that you guys heard
of that so this one has a great
advantage of it's going to get rid of
all that stuff I said of oh you know we
decided that this you know we only we're
gonna look at the data for the ones who
got care management versus the ones who
didn't instead we're gonna randomize a
whole bunch of people that probably
could get care management some will get
it some will get something else then
we're gonna follow their path and see
how they did that is the ideal way to
figure out what care management is doing
and if it's working right so if we knew
that answer for who it works and how
well it works then we're able to go back
to our predictive model and know what
kind of people we want to look for so I
said do we have a better way to
determine if something works yeah this
is where we do yes we can use tools of
science to determine the effect of
interventions and and so we started out
talking about predictive models I'm
gonna make you talk about interventions
because in healthcare that is how we
change the path of a patient right we're
gonna go do something we can't the data
buildings worth of data are not going to
make anybody healthier it's going to
have to take some interaction and and so
unfortunately if someone who doesn't is
not allowed to touch a patient that's
disappointing right so I don't get to
make any patients better but what I can
do is help models that allow clinicians
or or the healthcare system right we're
not just medical we could be thinking
about public health outreach and
different items but we want to think of
models that can really that there's a
real intervention involved and so you we
can perform a study of effectiveness of
care management and see what works and
what doesn't work I actually want to do
this right let's go ask what's an easy
way to do this without a randomized
control trial you can just go ask a care
manager give me your list of 100
patients tell me which ones you were
effective with which ones were
non-responsive let's go look at the
characteristics of those patients that
you felt like you were able to make a
difference with then we have a better
idea of who or then we're not wasting
the care managers time or and we're
better understand who who is right for
this treatment which is in this case
care manager so if we can build a model
to find those people that is the data
science that I'm aiming towards at least
in our models now do we do do this every
time I can tell you no but as people who
are thinking about predictive models and
the excitement about it in healthcare
recognizing that you're gonna always
want to peel back those layers of it's
not just risk it's not just risk of what
it's who's gonna respond well to the
invention right and so that's kind of
the mantra I'm trying to describe to our
leaders people who are directing
resources in terms of what can models do
for us is thinking about each
intervention and what model is best for
it and so the principle is a predictive
modeling that I think are important
right now is to flip the script
unfortunately we've gotten so we've
gotten distracted by the modeling itself
which is very cool you'll learn in
statistics and machine learning classes
you can do a lot of cool things it's fun
intellectual exercise to figure out how
good you can make your model and the
different tools but that model is gonna
do nothing unless we have an
intervention that goes with it right so
I would actually say go with the reverse
way so find an intervention that works
that's hard right that means going
clinicians sometimes don't always know
if they work but that's part of being an
academic health center is we're trying
to really decide you know what things
are working how well they work if we can
find something that works then and those
and we might be doing that through all
the trials and experiments that we
usually do in science then once we do
that then we can go find a model that
matches the interventions of the people
right
and so I always say you know tailor the
model to the intervention and I guess
this is but there's there's a model for
that and that is a lot of people are
saying oh we only want one risk model
all right so we're I've been in
discussions where people in New York oh
there's competing models out there you
know I just want one one model for the
risk of the patient they're like I'm
sorry though that's not going to be it
that's that's a very simplified version
that might be great because you just
have one score and all your different
reports for risk but we know that that's
probably not very useful because it's
risk of what risk of for what
intervention right that's the way the
modeling is is best designed as far as I
can see and so I want to encourage
people to say if you have an
intervention that works we can go build
a model for it and because of that
that's a lot of models right every
intervention we're
doing a lot of things in health care
hopefully we know what we're doing a lot
of times we haven't tested it but each
one of those things I think probably
deserves a model if it's if you can show
that it works it you know a data science
team should be able to build you a model
that isn't too time-consuming so you
know so that's you know a big thing
about healthcare data is remember when
we were talking about marketing they
know what works their product every time
right if the person sells it you know if
they sell the product that's a win
that's a success in health care we don't
always know what the success was we
don't always know what we did right that
that triggered a change in the health of
a patient and so those fundamental
issues that we have in healthcare are
not something that they face in
marketing in marketing if you send out a
hundred ads and you know you know 70
people don't care that's fine you got 30
hits that's great right in health care
if you perform 100 surgeries on someone
and somebody didn't need them that's not
good right we can't we can't take those
mistakes and so I think recognizing that
in in many of the other spaces where we
use data science the risk of failure is
much more lower it's not a big deal
and also the knowledge of what
intervention are you gonna deploy is
actually a lot more known you know
someone might like my product I give
them an ad I give them a link they're
probably you know pretty easy to know
what to do after that right
whereas in healthcare we're figuring
that all out it's a lot more complicated
and so now it's both I would say
daunting but also kind of exciting right
because this means that we're we have
you know there's a whole bunch of
interventions that I've never seen
models for there's a lot of things to go
build there's a lot of engagement with
clinicians to go and try to figure those
things out other factors that affect
predictive modeling we need to be able
to display risk factors and so when you
when you did your predictive typing
about you know Google searching
something it doesn't tell you why they
that phrase for you there's a whole
bunch of calculations that went with it
but it's really important in health care
that we know why something was what it's
selected for a patient partially it's
because clinicians have a very curious
mind and they also want it being control
and command of why what's happening to
the patient they need to know why they
can be sued if they don't know why right
and now does that happen all the time no
but in the back of my head if I'm
thinking about building a model I know
that they better know better agree with
why that model was saying that patient
deserves that treatment because one day
they might have to go tell someone why
why they chose that and so it's it
raises the bar we can't make mistakes we
have to raise the bar in terms of why
we've made a prediction what were the
data that went into it and all those
things
that's not something if you send out an
ad to the wrong person in marketing who
cares right it probably costs you 10
cents you know and so the other part is
of that is if you're going to display
the risk of a predictive model you need
to have probably a good visualization or
some way to do that and so there's been
different approaches for that and lots
of people are developing space but it's
it's not something to forget because I
know there's been people sending out
risk scores for years that have been
pretty much unusable because if you
don't know why someone's at risk then
you can't take the next step okay
and so in you know related to that is
how do you get the predictive models
into the workflow you know that most
electronic medical record systems will
have some ability to do that luckily
we're also developing new applications
that kind of can interact with those
systems that are more open source
because that way we you know we have
more flexibility and how we want people
to look at the data that we've been
working so hard to generate there's a
couple other slides that maybe not made
into the last set here
so one one you know one question is so
why is the health economist working as a
data scientist
right and you know the couple
United staes for one economy economists
are trained in statistics we have our
own version that's called econometrics
and what you may have heard of it's
essentially statistics for economics
just like bio stats and statistics for
by the biological areas each type of
discipline kind of has their version of
statistics which has been in some ways
customized they may have innovated and
developed in their own area computer
science turns out to have you know
they're learning statistics they've also
developed a ton of algorithms that have
really capitalize on the ability to use
computers to help with a lot of the
calculations so that's one reason health
economist is doing predictive modeling
another reason is that this issue of
causality right so we talked about oh
how do you know if an intervention
worked well if you just looked at the
data you might draw say that the
correlation between the care managers
and the the ones who got care management
first as long as you dint
oh it looks like there's a relationship
there but we know in many cases people
are actively choosing their environment
around them and that's something that
economists are used to I sometimes
compared it to epidemiology which is
more of an approach that you're exposed
to things right you're not choosing your
environment as many as much as you're
being exposed and his in the past they
were less likely to believe that there
there would be these causal kind of
endogenous issues that are going on now
the methodologies and epidemic
epidemiology have gotten a lot better
and they're much more able to understand
that there are you know to develop a
causal relationship which is what we
need for interventions to understand how
they work requires a little bit more
sophisticated methodology and then the
other question that you might have for
an economist is what are the four AI is
you know what's the impact on jobs is
this gonna eliminate this AI eliminate
jobs I think that's a common one I've
heard sometimes and I think what I hope
to kind of show you a little bit here is
there are more jobs tailoring every
intervention to a model that's a whole
bunch of work
trust me we have not figured out how to
do that you know with an algorithm it
requires going into figuring out you
know aligning the science with the you
know with the model and then making all
the customizations of it so I think
there's a real I mean I think there's a
lot of work in this area to come and so
people who said to me oh you know AI is
gonna get rid of all these jobs
certainly not if they're not if you're
one of the ones who are building models
and not even people who are kind of
interacting with them there's a lot of
human things that needs to happen for
these to work and so those are kind of
the main my main points that I wanted to
bring out today questions
transition and I'm just curious where
where you see sort of where along that
spectrum of modeling you think
healthcare isn't how long it'll take to
get to to the you know interventional
modeling or building models for
interventions I mean or are there are
you know and how many are out there now
and kind of where we we are definitely
in the beginning steps like I mean I can
tell you at OHSU we've had some basic
rules that have existed in our
healthcare system to help understand
risk we are you know just deploying some
of the active real-time models right now
and they're you know less than a dozen
of those I would say but I you know I
see it really flourishing once once
people kind of once we get the system's
down into how do we deploy how do we
evaluate it and and make sure that
everyone's protected there has been some
real resistance to yeah various kinds of
yeah there's various kinds of resistance
so you know initially a clinician will
usually look at it historically and
saying the score is wrong you know and
in if there's a black box you had no way
to say otherwise you're like oh why why
you know I don't know how it was
calculated so I can't tell you but now
like you said if you can display the
risk factors now we kind of can walk
through and of course on the inside we
always know it's usually being
calculated correctly whether or not it's
reflecting the patient is is something
else but so there's always a how
accurate is a score now that will that
kind of subsides after time as they get
exposed to the prediction and the
patient prediction and patient they
start seeing the pattern of you know
okay it's mostly right okay oh it it it
thinks when they're married that really
reduces their risk a lot right maybe
they maybe the clinician kind of
discounts that a little bit and say they
warm up to what the score is really
telling them over time so that is that
is the main thing is just getting people
comfortable with the idea of how do I
trust this enough
to feel like it's better than me
scouring through the chart by myself
that answer your question yeah great
presentation I had a question about what
their I'm curious in any of the
predictive models you've done whether
any of the end interventions have been
patient education I'm wondering if yeah
what the results have been with that and
I feel like that would be like Moses
yeah no no so like most of a lot of what
is done like in a clinic is not like the
intervention itself sometimes it's just
patient education about the issue and
yeah how that would sort of yeah so if
you know it's probably not gonna go into
the modeling itself but like I said so
that the process there would be alright
we we think that there are some patients
out there who aren't you know maybe
using the healthcare system quite right
and we think some education will make a
difference all right so we're gonna go
flag all those patients that we think
we're doing that and now let's go look
at factors that might predict that right
and then we go and try to deploy a model
that says all right we're pretty sure
these guys they have this weird behavior
first they go to the IDI and then they
go back to their clinic and then they
okay they look like they they don't know
how to manage their diabetes in the way
that we're kind of hoping that they will
and maybe our intervention is like let's
do education on how to what happens when
your sugar changes and what you're gonna
do next or whatever so there there's a
model there's a model for that right
have we done that not exactly we do have
a model actually that working in here is
one of the interns and we're cancer
patients have a lot of things that come
up their bodies are doing weird things
under chemo and that's unexpected to
them they get nervous they end up in the
edie and so part of it is us trying to
give them more information about what
might be happening with them how serious
is it and so there's a monitoring device
a iPad basically that will help them
kind of walk through symptoms that are
very common but new to them right
and so in a way that's kind of like an
education thing you know um so thank you
for your presentation
I'm also from an economics background
and so I'm wondering as an economist we
cover a lot of kind of ethics of
large-scale implementation of things I'm
thinking specifically in development
economics of like public health
incentives and actions but I wonder what
your thoughts are on the ethics of more
individual individualized implementation
specifically regarding the the random
control of kind of selecting at random
who gets a certain intervention versus
who doesn't okay yeah so so now we're
going back to the science part really of
thinking about how do we know if
something works and the randomized you
know the kind of the process for setting
up a good study that part where I said
some people get care management and some
people don't
that was a flip of the coin right how do
we decide that that's okay for patients
to not get something and that's
something so you know as you get more
exposed to research or something called
the institutional review board who's
gonna review your study and has certain
ethical principles in mind of you know
are you withholding something that
everyone knows is already good for a
patient that's probably not going to be
okay right they're gonna say nope we
can't do that study now if there's
something about it that we don't know if
there's uncertainty about it and we
don't think that they're you know being
withheld good care then that's something
we can randomize them to so you know but
that that's that's actually a very broad
research type question of you know can
we can we withhold care are we really
withholding it or are we experimenting
and and there's been and unfortunately
you know if you go into the history
there's been many terrible examples
where researchers have gone too far of
experimenting and stuff that they
shouldn't of kind of you know if they at
the consequence of
so we have much better protections now
so it's it still comes up so good
question
any other questions